catalytic converter thefts happen so
often that even the Oscar Mayer
Wienermobile isn't safe in fact our
story came up during today's State
Senate hearing on stopping catalytic
converter thefts Metro Police told state
senators that there were over 2500
reported thefts in their jurisdiction
last year now Senate Bill 243 would
arrest people for possessing a minimum
of two catalytic converters without
proof of ownership but Democratic state
senator Dallas Harris questions how that
process would work my concern is I'm
facing a felony and I'm trying to prove
something that I can't that I that I
can't prove
now a second bill would make that
catalytic converter thefts a misdemeanor
and not a felony and that has a hearing
scheduled for next Wednesday